estamos enfrentando el racismo sistémico
y la amenaza a nuestro planeta a través
del cambio climático y en medio de todo
esto tenemos un presidente que no
solamente es incapaz de enfrentar estas
crisis sino que nos está llevando por el
camino del autoritarismo esta elección
es la más importante en la historia
moderna de este país en respuesta a las
crisis sin precedentes que enfrentamos
necesitamos unas respuestas sin
precedentes un movimiento como nunca
antes de personas que estén preparadas
para levantarse y para luchar por la
democracia y la decencia y en contra de
la oligarquía y la intolerancia que
necesitamos yo bardem como nuestro
próximo presidente déjenme tomar esta
oportunidad para decir algo a las
millones de personas que apoyaron mi
campaña este año y también en el año
2016 amigos muchas gracias por su
confianza por su apoyo y por el amor
que me mostraron a mí ya mi familia
juntos hemos hecho aumentar este país en
una nueva dirección mostrando que todos
nosotros los americanos los latinos los
blancos los nativos los asiáticos los
homosexuales y los que no lo son
quieren una nación basada en los
principios de la justicia el amor y la
compasión nuestra campaña se terminó
hace ya varios meses pero nuestro
movimiento continúa y se está haciendo
cada vez más fuerte
muchas de las ideas que ahora parecemos
luchar que sólo hace unos años se
consideraban radicales ahora son comunes
pero déjenme ser claros y donaldson es
reelecto todo el progreso que hemos
alcanzado quedará dañado y esta elección
se trata de preservar y preservar
nuestras democracias durante este
presidente durante esta presidencia lo
impensable se ha vuelto normal él ha
tratado de evitar que la gente vote
ha tratado de socavar al sistema postal
ha desplegado a los agentes federales en
contra de manifestantes pacíficos ha
amenazado con retrasar la elección y ha
sugerido que no se irá de la oficina si
se en si pierden esto no es normal y
nunca debemos tratarlo como si fuera
normal bajo esta administración el
autoritarismo ha tomado raíz en nuestro
país mi familia y yo y muchos de ustedes
saben lo que puede hacer el
autoritarismo para destruir la
democracia la decencia y la humanidad
mientras que yo esté aquí trabajaré con
los progresistas con los moderados y si
también con los conservadores para
preservar y evitar que esta nación
sucumba ante esta amenaza ya que tantas
personas lucharon y murieron por
defender esos principios él no solamente
una amenaza para la democracia
aunque al rechazar la ciencia ha puesto
nuestras vidas y nuestra salud en
peligro y ha atacado a los doctores a
los científicos a aquellos que han
tratado de protegernos de la pareja y ha
evitado tomar una acción fuerte para
producir las máscaras y los guantes y
todo lo demás que tanto necesitan las
personas que nos atienden mientras la
casa se quema con juega al golf
sus acciones han resultado en más de
170.000 muertes y en una nación que aún
no está preparada para proteger a su
gente además la negligencia de zions ha
exacerbado la crisis económica que ahora
estamos experimentando desde que comenzó
esta pandemia más de 30 millones de
personas han perdido sus empleos y
muchos han perdido su seguro de salud
muchos familias trabajadoras se están
preguntando cómo van a darle de comer a
sus hijos
y se preocupan de que puedan ser sacados
de sus hogares y cómo ha respondido 8 en
lugar de mantener el apoyo de
desempleados 600 dólares semanales y los
cheques de 1200 dólares de emergencia
que muchos recibieron en lugar de ayudar
a los pequeños negocios
creó órdenes de ejecutivos fraudulentas
que básicamente no hacen nada para
atender esta crisis mientras que al
mismo tiempo amenaza el futuro de la
seguridad social y medicare pero la
verdad es que incluso antes de la
respuesta negligente de champ a la
pandemia muchas personas trabajadores
muchas familias ya estaban en un ya no
tenían esperanza de poder salir adelante
juntos debemos construir una nación que
sea más equitativa más compasiva
y que incluye a todos se que joe biden
comenzará esa lucha desde el primer día
déjeme ofrecerle unos cuantos ejemplos
de cómo yo by the nos va a llevarse
adiós joe biden apoya el aumento del
salario mínimo a 15 dólares por hora
esto le dará a 40 millones de
trabajadores un aumento y levantará a
esa escala para todos los demás para que
sea más fácil que la gente se puede unir
a sindicatos creando 12 semanas de
sanidad paga y hará que el servicio para
los niños sea asequible para muchos se
va a reconstruir nuestra infraestructura
y enfrentar la crisis el cambio
climático llevándonos a una transición
hacia 100 por ciento de energía limpia
en los próximos 15 años estas
iniciativas van a crear millones de
buenos empleos que pagan bien en todo el
país
como ustedes saben somos la única nación
industrializada que no garantiza la
salud para todos sus habitantes mientras
que joe y yo no estamos de acuerdo en la
mejor manera o el mejor camino para
llegar a una cobertura universal él si
tiene un plan que va a expandir de gran
manera el cuidado de salud el servicio
de salud y a recortar el costo de los
medicamentos va a reducir la edad para
ser elegible para medicare de 65 a 60
para ayudar a reformar nuestro sistema
criminal que está roto él va a acabar
con los centros de detención privados y
el camino que lleva de la escuela
directamente a las prisiones él va a
acabar con el odio y con la división que
camps ha creado él va a detener la
satanización de inmigrantes el culto a
los blancos nacionalistas
la intolerancia y los ataques a las
mujeres queridos amigos les digo ustedes
y a todos aquellos que apoyaron a otros
candidatos en la primaria y a todos
aquellos que tal vez hayan votado por
donald trump en la última lección el
futuro de nuestra democracia está en
juego el futuro de nuestra economía está
en juego el futuro de nuestro planeta
está en juego tenemos que unirnos
derrotar a la nación y elegir a joe
biden y a kamala harris como nuestro
próximo presidente y vicepresidente
queridos amigos en el precio de fallar o
simplemente es demasiado grande para
imaginar gracias